your new book that just came out is now
that's funny and I understand that it's
24 writers and you give them a premise
like a situation about a mother and
daughter and instead of asking them
about their process because I understand
you say that's the fastest way to get
fiction from an artist is to ask them
what their creative process is well you
know when you interview somebody and you
ask them about their process you have no
idea what you're getting and a lot of
people sort of romanticize the way they
wish their process was some will tell
you what they think they do but the
easiest way to get at it the most direct
ways to say do it and we'll watch and
these people were so nice about letting
us do that and one of the things that we
thought was really interesting is the
people we had had major credits I mean
these were people who were show runners
a lot of these were show creators and
all of them at one point or another said
what kind of nervous doing this because
we have one shot at this and then we're
going to be compared to our really
really famous peers who might do a
better job and we want to you when it's
time did you give them to work out this
premise as much time as they the the
average interview was anywhere from
about an hour to two hours or so and
that was it they charged what you're
reading in the book is a liberally had
edited so we were very sure the most
important thing to us was the the
premise making because you get 24
different stories from this one premise
and but great questions come out of it
too but the most important thing that we
were sure not to cut was the was the the
premise work and I think it it comes
across and then the little stories that
we tell the little what do you call them
I was forget what you call them well I
mean we tried two sidebars we we try to
put some of our own insights into it
when we saw something
and every once in a while we'd see
something really unusual we'd see trends
like a surprisingly large number of the
writers had graduate degrees in math and
science as a mean that's weird for
comedy writers and one of the things
that we found interesting is
particularly for TV comedy writers
people in a room they tend to be more
story guys or joke guys and the science
math guys almost exclusively story guys
they were well organized and they were
really good at plotting a lot of the
people we we interviewed also had
stand-up backgrounds and they tended to
be much more surprisingly the joke guys
I think there was one funny story that
louche Nider
who wrote for Everybody Loves Raymond
told us a story that he was they were
sitting around the table and one of the
guys grabs him and pulls him under the
table and he says pitch this joke for me
says pitch at yourself he says no no
you've done stand-up I wanted to make
sure this gets in you'll tell her better
than me so people knowing their skillset
and and you know what if we were to give
you a premise our own premise I'm
curious how the two of you would work it
out it would be brilliant I mean I'm
pretty sure it would be it would take a
couple hours it would okay Pete I'm you
know he feel free to correct me but my
observation is that I've talked about
this a lot with my students because the
a good way to go out of a university
especially as an undergrad is with a
partner they are much more likely to
hire you as a partner when you're young
and help you develop your craft then as
a solo writer I'm talking about comedy
now I don't know anything about how
drama works but I'm pretty sure that
there's so much cross-pollination now
it's the same but the way Peter is it's
too quick I got way away from the story
I don't know what talk of my own today I
have no idea i-i-i believe that it is
really a bad thing for people to have
the same skills when there
this goes toward answering the premise
question you have if both people in the
partnership have the same skills I don't
see a reason for the partnership
complementary skills Peter is he has two
things one drives me crazy he is able to
put anything down as a draft he has no
blocks how he can even call himself a
writer without blocks is shameful but
he'll just put it down knowing it's
awful it's not ever as awful as he
thinks it is and then he'll say to me
can you work on this and develop it so
whereas I would rather have dental
surgery than do a first draft it's
painful for me but I love rewriting and
Peter is is capable of seeing structure
in his head I think this comes in part
from his science background
I'll start anywhere in the story and
just let it write itself and both of
those ways of working on developing a
premise or anything else are valid you
know the one thing we've learned from
this book is there isn't any one way to
do it I don't know if I answered your
question but I liked my answer I have a
little blabbermouth going on today is
that sort of answer the question if we
haven't gotten to it yet the question
but but I will throw in one other my
partnership but one other sort of
interesting thing that we'll get to
it'll be for play for the question oh
good which is he is a result left there
was a really there was a really huge
study on creativity done at Berkeley
years ago and it wasn't just creative
artists there was architects doctors
also it's also all across fields and the
two major findings that they came out
with were creative people or have a
better ability to tolerate ambiguity and
really important they have the ability
to suspend judgment and one of the
things you find particularly with young
writers is they'll write something then
they immediately get depressing it's not
great
not good enough right one of the things
and one of the things that that we've
learned and that for sure helps me is I
want to get something down we again like
the the old Hemingway quote right drunk
at its sober so once you get something
down then you have something to work on
and I've never written anything that
looks at the end like it started out at
the beginning so I don't I don't feel
constrained about writing anything
because I know it's going to get
reshaped retool reworked yeah I don't
have that
you